how's it going ladies and gents welcome
to a video on codetech tutorial today
we're going to be talking about getting
the ogre 3d rendering system up and
going with c plus plus
so i'm just going to walk you through it
i'm going to talk about building it from
source you can go get the binaries and
but i i think building from source is
the way to do it if you're going to use
it in one of your projects because you
can you can get the most up-to-date
version and you can change little things
if you want to and stuff like that
so while their
website is here and you can go to
downloads and download ogre
i'm not sure what ogre next is it might
just be something further
but this one
well
this way yeah you can get the source
code here it looks like it's off github
and comes in a zip
and there's the sdks
but like i said we're going to be
building it from source so we're going
to go over to github
github.com
and we're just going to search for over
here we'll see over cave over 3d or just
over
and this is it
so as you can see this has been updated
two days ago so this is an active
development
what we're going to do is just copy the
link here
and we want to clone it
if you don't want to deal with github
and cloning then you can download the
zip of the file
probably in releases over here
but we're going to talk about cloning it
so we get the latest version so make
sure you copy that
and then you want to clone it with
whatever you have i'm using windows here
uh clearly i'm going to be using fork
so with fork
work is just a free github thing go to
file clone and paste it in make sure you
got your folders how you want them and
it clones
so as you can see here i've already
cloned it
and i've got it downloaded so now that i
have it downloaded
what you want to do next is
operate off the cmg file because as you
can see here it does use cmg
so i'm actually just going to minimize
this for
and i'm going to go open
my cmake
this is the cmake gui
what you want to do is just browse to
your source
wherever you downloaded it i have it in
repose over
and hit select
and then you want to browse to a build
now i'm using a pretty standard build
location
where is it okay i'm already in it
yeah so under repose over you can build
it wherever you want but the standard is
in
into a folder called alt and then into a
folder called build
there you go same place just make those
two folders or sometimes people just use
just build but the windows default seems
to want to be out slash build so it's
pretty standard for windows
right there
and then all you do is you hit configure
over here next
once it's done configuring it will take
a while hopefully it has no errors if it
does have any errors go look at them it
might say you need some sort of driver
or something if you don't have your
drivers updated but
most likely
it will be fine so when you do hit
configure it isn't going to ask you for
what
yeah it says i'm missing some python
stuff so i can't use that and you hit
generate and you want to also make sure
you generate it from
microsoft visual studio you don't see
the pop-up here because i've already
done it
but it'll pop up and ask you at some
point what your generator is and you can
see mine here is already visual studio
16 2019 so you just want to pick the
same thing or if you're watching this
from the past it might be a newer
version of visual studio
or watching this from the future i don't
know there's a little inception going
right there going on right there so once
it's done configuring and generating you
can just open it with visual studio and
you can do the click this button right
here to do it
or
let me close my current project here
if we click this button it should just
open the solution file
with visual studio you should have it
all ready
and what you'll see here is something
that looks like this
you can go to switch views folder view
looks like it's taking a second to
switch there we go or switch views
and one of these is
well i'm not seeing it here okay
okay let's do this different way
so apparently that opened us something a
little weird
let's take a look here
the big thing is i want you to be able
to figure out how to get around these
weird errors but we should see something
like all build
and stuff like that i'm not seeing it
here so i'm going to just
open visual studio on its own
and
let's see open a project or solution
and we'll just go to it
wherever you
downloaded it to
ogre
and then wherever you built it to out
build you should see it over dot sla
and when you open there you'll get the
full project this is the same thing
i'm just not seeing the all build and
all that stuff for some reason
okay so just overdose solution
okay it's just in this folder
you make predefined targets now it might
not be in a folder these might be in
separate areas here
so the first thing you generally want to
do isn't all build so you want to right
click on this and just click build
or when
or since it's a default it's the bold
one you can go up here and you build or
you can use the hotkey however you want
to build it you basically want to just
build everything now this is going to
take a while so you might want to uh
you'll get a cup of coffee or whatever
while it's building
if i hit this it should go pretty quick
because i've already done it
basically just say 28 up to date now
when this is done you should get a
message at the bottom it tells you how
many succeeded if you have failures
you'll need to address those i didn't
have any when i built it it just built
fine so that was cool
other things that are real obvious that
i haven't mentioned like
of course you need visual studio so it's
free just go get it and make sure you
get the c plus plus packages with it
when you update it and all that
all right so it runs um yeah visual
studio also has some cmake integration
so of course you need cmake i didn't
really mention all that because it's
just obvious
okay so another real important thing
here is
you also want to build this install
this install actually sets up the sdk
because all build is just all the source
code and everything this install is what
puts the sdk
on your folder in your
little over output folder
as you can see i'm getting all these
up-to-date messages because i've already
done it
this is what you actually need to put it
in your project and work with it in your
project is well you need both
but the sdk is also very important you
won't be able to continue with your
project if you don't have it
so once you're done building all these
you can actually just exit or just
actually you know go to file
new
project
and i'm going to show you now how to use
ogre now that you've got it built
so you
let's start with an empty project
and we'll just call it
uh
poger
tutorial
now i'm really only going to go through
the
very start of this tutorial
i'll show you where to take it further
but there's no need for me to like
go through a ton because it's it's all
documented so i'm just really showing
you the parts that aren't documented
very well like this whole building
setting up
there's there's no guide to doing this
on windows even though it's pretty
straightforward the guide they do have
is all about linux really
which is fine too
okay so now i've got just a
a blank visual studio
i'm going to go ahead and switch this to
release and 64. and the reason i'm doing
that i kind of glazed over this before
but i'll say it now
is when i was building
over i built it as release in 64. so all
the libraries and dlls that it built
for the over sdk and everything were in
release 64. so you want your project to
match if you built and debug 86 or
release 86 and you have to your project
has to match or you can go back and
build the other versions
so they just they just have to match the
libraries have to match such the stuff c
plus plus thing you can't use x
86 uh libraries with 64 and stuff like
that
and you might be able to use debug ones
but it'll probably give you a bunch of
error messages i'm not sure you should
just match them up
and release with dev info or min size
release is fine it'll it'll work with
release as well
i'm not going to get into the nuances of
that all right so what we're going to do
here is just make a main file i'm just
going to right click somewhere and just
go to add
new item
and we'll just make a c plus plus file
and i'm just going to name it
and use probably the same see just
main.cpp
so of course
i'll do and include
well
it's going to be over right you're going
to include ogre
or actually
i'll include anything yet just uh just
put a main in here because it's going to
be all over stuff and we're going to
make a class to handle all that
so then we're going to make another
folder here
add
class
and we'll just make this class name the
uh
uh ogre
whatever just it's going to be our
implementation basically
so i'll just call it over
it's called over
in sounds good to me all right now the
rest of this here
we're actually going to go to a tutorial
so i'm going to go back into chrome here
go back into the c ogre
and here they've got documentation api
reference
and there's a bunch of stuff here now if
you go right to tutorials over here
you'll start getting some how to use it
now that you've got a bill you should be
able to generally go through these
tutorials
so there's a guide to building
ogre we already went through this it
gives you some linux steps so if you're
doing it on linux some of these work it
doesn't really talk about windows on
here i guess you could
kind of adapt it but it doesn't really
talk about the way i did it at all so
looks like you can build it as a
visual studio package
vc package
so that's pretty interesting too
that's uh
that's a whole nother way of doing it
i'm since i'm building it from source
there's yeah since i just walked through
building from source we're going to skip
over all this and out here it talks
about setting up your first over project
and it basically tells you
um
cmake version of it now i've done some
recent tutorials on cmake but we're not
going to be using that we're just going
to be using visual studio stuff right
now
if you're using cmake
you should be able to figure this out if
you're familiar with cmake but the
important things to extract from here is
it has a target link libraries such as
over bits and over rt shader system so
it's given us a pretty good hint here of
what we need
to be linking in our project
so and while it doesn't talk about
visual studio here we can still
abstract out of here what we need to set
up in our linker and all of that
so let's go ahead and do that over bytes
over
rt shader system
all right so back into visual studio
here we're going to right click
and go to properties there's a bunch of
different ways to see the properties
here you basically want to go to your
project properties
and in here it'll go let's see we're
going to need to do a few things here
we're going to go to the linker
and in general
there's an additional library
directories
so
for now we're just going to pass this
uh standard way click folder click these
little things
and go to the repo where
you
built over
repo or where you downloaded it should
just be lowercase ogre that's how it
came out for me
and we want to
look for includes which are in over main
include there it is
and there's a few others we need in here
too
so click this again
click this again
go back to the same spot
and we're also going to need components
and there's there's the bits or bytes
and include
and we're going to do this once again go
back to the same spot
over
components and rt shader system
so if you start using other of these
parts as you go on you're going to need
to add them as well
and i think that's actually there's one
more i know we're going to need and it's
one
for the version that we built
so you'll also go into it again this
time to alt
build
and include
because this has a version config
in the build
oops and i accidentally overwrote one of
mine so i need to add that back in
i'll just go ahead and do that real
quick
there was the shader system that it
overrode
accidentally yep okay so now we should
have basically these four
and that should be good we'll go ahead
and apply that
oops
those were supposed to be library
directories
or uh include directories i put them in
the library
that's fine we can just
copy all these i believe
i'm just gonna do a little notepad hack
here
now i'm gonna need them so i'm just
gonna open up notepad and paste them in
doesn't let you multi-select so
i'm doing it this way
all right so actually what we need here
and on
uh food borrowed this all right well
hopefully i don't make it too confusing
but in the linker additional library
directories
we need the library locations which is
sort of similar
into the repo into over but these are
built so we go to alt
build
live
and that's it
hit okay
this is where all the static libraries
are
all right and under c plus plus the one
above linker this is where you need
and then under general this is where you
need all the additional include
directories
so we'll add all these in i'm just going
to let me put them all in at once it'd
be cool if it did if it does
no it doesn't seem to let me
so we'll just put all these in i'll just
do them one at a time that one
add another one
i'll let you paste
i guess i didn't cut correctly or
something
but
there we go
so it's hitting the wrong key
yeah we basically just want to get all
these added in here
and the last one there
okay
there we go okay apply
so that was in sequel split general hope
that's not too confusing
all right and in the linkers we do want
to link
so that's under input
now that it points to where the
libraries are we can actually now just
put these dependencies in here
and they're just like they said on that
tutorial basically
let's see
here we are
over bits and the over rt shader system
so we're going to need both of those
linked
they do need to be on separate lines and
they do need
live on them
live
and if we need any more we'll go in
there and add them
that should be good
so there's also going to be the dlls
because this does have runtime dlls
and i'll get that that a little later
actually heck let's just do it now while
we're setting up everything else
so what you want to do here is
just go
open your file explorer
go to where you uh built it
repose over
alt build
and bin
under ben here
well i built as men size release so
that's where they're all going to be
if you build as debug or release or
whatever you'll find them in there too
so these are the types that match your
build
and i just did a sort by type so i could
see all the dlls
you just want to grab all the dlls here
and you want to do a copy
so
however you want to copy these
you basically want to copy them into
your project directory i'm just going to
right click on this open file explorer
and here we go
so this is like the root of the project
but then there's a name
folder here this is where you want them
to be
it's going to look a little messy
organize if you want but basically these
dlls just need to be on the root
and
yeah these are shared libraries
so there might be another way of doing
it where you reference them from your
development libraries but a lot of them
need to ship with your software
because likely you're whoever you're
shipping it to will need the runtime
stuff they probably won't have all this
over stuff on their computer
so you might as well get in there
project but some of them are huge like
this one's four meg this one's about
three meg
you don't necessarily want to be
uploading them to github and stuff like
that
because they're not gonna change very
often
but that's that's kind of up to you
you want to do that but now that they're
in there once we're done building it
will run without an error if you get a
dll error you didn't do the step
basically
you didn't get them in here in the right
place
okay
there's also another thing that we're
going to get into here in a second ogre
uses config files
and we'll see those let's see here
you actually see those in your build
the tests samples resources plugins
we will need the plugins and resources
so i'm going to go ahead and copy those
over and those go in the same places
same place as the dll
so there we go i'm just gonna paste them
on in there
and if you don't have them you'll find
out later because it'll say it won't be
able to find the models basically these
default ones here that built with it
they point to some of the sdk
models and demo message message meshes
and stuff like that
all right so let's go get ahead and get
into that tutorial a little bit further
now that we've sorted all that out
so we went through the configuration we
linked all this stuff
um
here it points to well they do a file
copy of the resources here we're gonna
need that i guess we don't necessarily
need the plugins yet but
so what we just did there was basically
that
and of course they just add an
executable so this is this here the
cmake thing is very similar to what we
just did basically
okay so it now kind of gives you a setup
for to build an application skeleton
and it gives you some code
it basically has you build a little
class that extends application context
and the input listener
so this will get you a window
and your rendering uh surface basically
and then some stuff so you can set up
keys
so it's a very default
uh little place to render with a window
and it uses sdl2 for the window if you
want to use a different windowing system
you can just the default one here is
sdl2
and then it has you set up
the class with a key press
where the escape key
will
basically end the scene
and it also does a
setup that basically initializes
everything
so really what we can do is just copy
all of this
or we can build it out however you want
to do it so i'm just going to do it like
this i'm going to move to the side move
this over here
and
yeah we've got our main files
we've got them all up here tab so i'm
just gonna collapse this on down
and in the dot h file we basically want
to make sure we get this class set up
correctly
so we're going to need to
put this extension on it
we're not using the my test app name
we're using ogram
and we'll put it on a new line so you
can actually see it
as you can see we need to do some
includes it doesn't it doesn't know what
this over byte stuff is
so we need to include
and it should see it here since we did
all the properties there's ogre
i think we actually need over
bytes
and it should be happy it's not happy
okay so if you want the full list of
source code here for what we're actually
doing it's actually in your build
back where you built
uh
ogre
or just actually on the default repo
there is a samples area
down at the bottom there's a tutorials
and the bootstrap one right here
is actually all the code so
i'm just going to make this a little
simpler and and just put it all in one
file
i don't want to be sitting here typing
all day
but we're going to delete this
class that i started making
delete
and i guess this is good practice if you
want to know how to mess around with
files here in visual studio
if nothing else so we're just going to
open this i'm just going to do an edit
so it opens with different software
and there it is
so i'm just going to do a copy
and a paste
and now you'll see that there is a main
on the bottom here but we do have this
main in here but above it we basically
just have the full class
there is the header for the class right
there
and here is
all the definitions of everything
there's the key press thing
and there's that setup
and you can see you can walk through all
what this setup does
and
there's the main now we can actually
build and run this
and let's just go ahead and do it let's
just hit this debugger here
which should build it yes there's no
errors it'll run it right away
now uh it does give a bunch of warnings
see there you have a bunch of warnings
and here we get in um so ignore all the
warnings those are all just
part of over not really something you
can do about
um
unless you want to edit their source
code and make a
make a pull request over but uh we're
not getting into that so we do have an
error at the bottom this is the only
important thing here and it says cannot
open input file over bytes.live so we do
have to address that so let's just go
back into our properties and see what we
did wrong
live that looks fine
let's go ahead and go back to general
edit let's just double check that this
library is correct
this uh path to it
over
out build
live
there it is
okay we
we have to go further down and live into
a min size release because that's what
we built that's the error
you just had to go one folder deeper now
it should be fine
because it just wasn't in that directory
so now let's go ahead and go to build
again
and it looks like it's a little bit
better but we are still seeing an error
it's with the ogre scene node we haven't
linked to the ogre library apparently
they didn't need to do that in their
tutorial but here you definitely do
so we'll go back into properties
essentially the same thing we're just
going to add
two additional dependencies in here and
we're not going to put over main.live
that should take care of it
there it looks good we got a one
succeeded so now if we hit play we
should get our initial
bootstrap
since we've already copied in the config
and dlls it's not going to crash
you get a crash
it could tell you either something about
a config or dll
there we go we got a little sinbad dude
and if you hit escape it exits now the
first time it pops up is going to prompt
you for a rendering setup probably
it might
so you'll get to choose on a little
screen if you didn't see that here
because i've already ran it i think
not entirely sure
but
you might get a pop-up that asks you
what you want to render with
all right and that's basically it so you
can go further with this
you can uh this is just the very intro
getting that little world going
but as you saw there were other
tutorials in that folder
oh we're in this folder there's a a one
and then a two
then you can back up and there's other
stuff in here
but what i would recommend is walking
through this
so
there we go
so we did all this basically
we went through
this whole setting up your over project
so next would be your first scene and
then it starts getting into scenes and
entities then you can go to lights
camera shadows
brains sky fog and you can basically go
the whole route and learn ogre
so uh let me know if you have any
questions below let me know if you have
any trouble i'll see what i can do to
help
i have not tested this directly on linux
yet i'm probably going to do that uh at
a later date
but i hope these steps were good enough
i did kind of do it on the fly i really
just
built all this and did this a couple
hours ago and then decided now go ahead
and make a video
and uh
yeah
i feel like this was necessary because
i could not really find any sort of
video tutorials about this
and uh
yeah i just remember when i was new to c
plus plus and trying to get this going i
could not figure it out so i hope this
helps someone out there that is stuck
all right we'll see in the next video
peace out guys